- 「量子情報と計算の理解」に
戻ってきた。
John Watrousだ。IBM Quantumの
教育テクニカルディレクターをやっている。
このシリーズの第2レッスンだ。まだ
第1レッスンを見ていないなら、必ず確認してくれ。
第1レッスンで話した内容を
直接土台にしていくから、
このレッスンに入る前にその内容を
理解しておくことが大事だ。
それから、このシリーズには
動画に加えて教科書コンテンツも
含まれていることを
覚えておいてくれ。リンクは
動画の概要欄にある。これはシリーズの
ユニット1の第2レッスンだ。
ユニット1では量子情報の
基礎を扱っていく。
前のレッスンでは、単一システムの設定での
量子情報について話した。つまり、情報を
格納する1つのシステムがあって、
それが単独でどう機能するかを
説明していった。
古典情報にかなりの時間を
費やしたが、主に参照点を確立して、
量子情報と古典情報の数学的な
類似点を浮き彫りにするためだ。
量子情報と古典情報の間のね。
また、量子状態がベクトルで
表現できること、具体的には複素数の
成分を持ちユークリッドノルムが1に等しい
ベクトルで表現できることも見た。
そして標準基底測定と
ユニタリ演算について議論した。
このレッスンでは、量子情報を
格納できる複数のシステムへと
視野を広げていく。
これは単純に、各個別システムが
前回議論したように機能するということを
言っているだけじゃない。全体が
部分の和よりも大きいという意味があって、
それは確率が絡む場合の
古典情報でも同様だ。
複数のシステムは
互いに相互作用できるし、
例えば互いに相関することもできる。
そして量子の設定では、この可能性も含まれる——
システムがエンタングルしている
という可能性だ。これは以前
耳にしたことがある言葉かもしれない。
エンタングルメントは量子情報において
非常に重要な現象で、シリーズが続く中で
さらに多くのことを話していく。
しかし、複数システムの量子情報を
考えて理解するために
かなりの足がかりを与えてくれる
シンプルな原理がある。
それは、2つ以上のシステムを
常に組み合わせて、あるいは
概念的にまとめて
考えて、1つの複合システムを
形成しているかのように見ることができる、ということだ。
そしてこのような複合システムを
単一システムであるかのように考えるとき、
前回学んだすべてと
整合した方法で記述されなければ
ならないと気づく。
単一システムの前のレッスンでね。
これがどう機能するか、
そして複数システムの量子情報の
記述が単一システムでの
機能の仕方からどう自然に生まれてくるかを見ていく。
この1つの原理に基づいてね。レッスンの概要を示す。
偶然にも前回のレッスンの概要と同じになっているが、
今回は単一システムではなく
複数システムに焦点を当てる。
前のレッスンと同じように、
そして全く同じ理由で、
古典情報から
始めていく。
またしても、量子情報と古典情報が
数学的なレベルでどう機能するかの
非常に密接な類似点が
見えてくるだろう。
このように古典情報にそれほど
焦点を当てたり、各レッスンを
古典情報から始めたりすることは
通常はしない。
後続のレッスンは量子情報と
計算にもっと専ら
焦点を当てる傾向に
なっていく。
でも始まりのここでは
これが理にかなったアプローチで、
古典情報について考えることが
量子情報を理解するための
貴重な指針の源になれるという
考えに立ち戻っている。
このレッスンのこのパートでは
テンソル積という重要な概念も
議論していく。
テンソル積は量子情報において
極めて重要だが、
古典的な設定でも
現れてくる。
それから量子情報に移って、
前のレッスンとよく似た形で
量子状態、標準基底測定について議論していく。
そして今回は複数システムの
ユニタリ演算について話す。
まず複数システムの
古典状態について
話し始めよう。
前のレッスンを思い出してほしいが、
システムの古典状態とは
そのシステムの配置のことで、
明確に認識され説明できる——
不確実性や誤りなしにね。
そして数学的な言葉では、
古典状態集合と言うとき、
単に有限で空でない集合を
意味している。
複数システムの議論を
始めるにあたって、
XとYという2つのシステムが
あると仮定しよう。
Xには前のレッスンと同じく
シグマと呼ぶ古典状態の集合があって、
Yには古典状態の集合がある——
それをガンマと呼ぶ。集合シグマとガンマは
同じ集合でも異なる集合でも構わない。
でも別の名前をつけているのは、
異なる集合になり得るというだけでなく、
別の名前をつけることで
物事を明確に保つのに役立つからだ。
この議論全体を
2つのシステムから任意の数のシステムへ
一般化するのは
かなり簡単だとわかるだろう。でも2つのシステムから始めることで、
詳細に埋もれることなく
基本的なアイデアに
集中できる。
XとYを並べて、Xを左、Yを右に置いて、この2つのシステムをまとめて見ると
まるで1つの複合システムを形成しているかのようだ。
この新しいシステムに名前をつけるために、こんな風に順序対として書くか、あるいは単純に2つの文字をこのように並べることができる。
どちらも一般的な書き方で、好きな方や使いやすい方を選べばいい。
どちらの場合も、XYと読む。
この時点で非常に自然に浮かぶ疑問は、この新しい複合システムXYの古典状態とは何か、ということだ。
その疑問への答えは、XYの古典状態集合は2つの古典状態集合の直積だ、ということだ。
シグマとガンマ、ここに定義が示されているのが分かる。
ある瞬間において、Xはシグマの要素である何らかの古典状態を持ち、Yはガンマの要素である何らかの古典状態を持っている。
そして、この2つの状態をまとめて、まるで1つの状態を形成しているかのように考えるわけで、それがまさに
直積が捉える概念だ。それぞれの集合から1つずつ、合わせて2つの要素があり、この2つの要素をまとめて
1つの集合の1つの要素を形成しているかのように考えたい。
明確にしておくと、ここには1つの前提がある。それは、どちらのシステムがXでどちらがYかを分かっている、ということだ。
そして両者の間に混乱はない。Xが物理的に左側にあり、Yが右にあることは重要ではない。
むしろ、2つのシステムが区別可能であり、どちらがどちらかを把握できるように、こういう順序にしようと決めた、ということが重要なんだ。
とてもシンプルな例を見てみよう。シグマが2値アルファベットで、ガンマがトランプの4つのスートを含む集合だ。
Xが2値を格納し、Yがトランプの4つのスートのうち1つを格納するとすると、8つの古典状態が存在する。
XYのペアの可能な古典状態は、ここに列挙されているのが分かる。
3つ以上のシステムの場合、これは素直な方法で一般化される。
特に、X1からXnがそれぞれシグマ1からシグマnという古典状態集合を持つシステムだとすると、
n個のシステムをまとめて1つのシステムとして見た場合、古典状態集合は直積で与えられる。
n個の古典状態集合シグマ1からシグマnの直積だ。
画面右にある通り、直積は任意の集合の数に対してこのように定義できる。
例えば、3つのシステムがあり、すべてが古典状態集合として2値アルファベットを共有しているとする。つまり、3ビットがある、ということだ。
その場合、1つのシステムとしてまとめて見た3ビットの取り得る古典状態は8つあり、ここに列挙されているのが分かる。
各システムは個別に状態0か1になれ、考えられる全ての組み合わせを網羅している。
古典状態のn組は、括弧とカンマを省略した文字列として書くこともできる。ここに示されている通りだ。
これは、特に古典状態を記号として考えるときに理にかなっていて、2値アルファベットという非常によくある例がそうだ。
何度も立ち戻ってきたこの例では、こうする方が非常に便利なことがあり、式がシンプルになる傾向がある。
そして煩雑さが減る。文字列という概念は実際、直積を通じて数学的な形式で定式化されているんだ。
つまりこれは単なる別の表記法であって、概念的に異なるものではない。
例として、10ビットX1からX10があるとしよう。
その場合、例えばコンピュータの10ビットレジスタとして自然に考えられる、10ビットをまとめた古典状態集合は、
2値アルファベットとそれ自身の10重直積だ。
それらの状態を文字列として書くと、ここに示されているようになる。1,024個あり、
もちろん全ては列挙されていない。ここにある3つの点は、推測できるパターンがあることを示しているはずで、
おそらく意図は伝わるだろう。さて、直積集合の要素を順序付けするための慣習がある。
これは、確率的状態と量子状態の両方をベクトルとして表現するために、明確にしておくことが重要だ。
その慣習は、直積集合の要素を辞書式順序で並べる、というものだ。これは基本的に辞書順を意味する。
より具体的には、直積を取る個々の集合それぞれがすでに独自の順序を持っているという前提から始め、
n組や文字列を1つの単語とみなし、アルファベット順に並べる。
別の言い方をすると、n組や文字列内の位置は左から右へと重要度が下がっていく、ということだ。
ちょうど0から9の数字を使って数を書くときと同じだ。
これを明確にするための例を示そう。
1、2、3を含む集合と2値アルファベットの直積を取ると、6つの要素を含む集合が得られる。
ここでは説明されている順序で列挙されている。
1番目の位置に1を持つ全ての要素は、1番目の位置に2を持つ全ての要素より前に来て、さらにそれらは全ての要素より前に来る。
最初の位置に3がある場合。最初の位置で2つの要素が
一致するときは、2番目の位置の順序に
従う。
それが直積に使う
順序だ。
この慣習を使ってn組を文字列として書くと、非常に馴染み深いパターンが見えてくる。
例えば、2値アルファベットとそれ自身の直積は、
ここに見えるように順序付けられる。
これらの文字列を、非負の整数の
2進数表現として見れば、数値順に並んでいると考えられ、
これは一般化できる。
任意の文字列長に。確率的状態に移ろう。前回のレッスンですでに知っているように、
確率的状態とは、与えられたシステムの各古典的な
状態に確率を対応させるものだ。
2つ以上のシステムを組み合わせて、
まるで1つの
システムを形成するかのように集合的に扱う複合システムがある場合、
この複合システムの確率的状態は、
個々のシステムの直積の要素に
確率を割り当てなければならない。
古典的状態の集合に。なぜなら、それが
複合システムの古典的状態の集合だからだ。
例えば、
XとYがビットだとすると、XYの
確率的状態のこの例がある。
両方のビットが0になる確率は2分の1で、
両方のビットが1になる確率も2分の1だ。
つまり2つのビットが異なる値を取ることはない。
これはXYの有効な確率的状態であり、
ベクトルとして
別の形で書くこともできる。
ここで見えるように。先ほど説明した
古典的状態の順序付けの慣習に
従っているのが分かる。
これはXとYが相関している
確率的状態の例であり、「全体は
部分の総和より大きい」という意味だ。前に示唆したように、単に
Xの確率的状態と
Yの確率的状態があってそれらを組み合わせるのではなく、
まずシステムを
組み合わせてから、
その後で
複合システムの確率的状態を
考えるわけだ。
システム間の相関をより正確に
述べるために、独立性の
概念を定義することから始める。これは本質的に
相関のない状態だ。
ここで言う独立性とは、
例えばベクトルの線形独立性とは対照的に、
統計的独立性を指している。
これは確率と統計における
基本的な概念だ。
2つのシステムXとYがあり、XYの
確率的状態を考えているとき、
XとYが独立であると言う。
ここに見える式が、XとYの
すべての古典的状態aとbの
選択に対して成り立つ場合だ。
この独立性の条件を解釈する一つの方法は、
Xがある古典的状態にある確率が
Yが別の古典的状態にある確率と
まったく無関係であると
言っていることだ。
つまり、一方のシステムがどの状態にあるかを知っても、
もう一方のシステムの状態に関連する
確率には影響しないということだ。
ある手順に従ってXの古典的状態を
ランダムに選び、次にYの
古典的状態を
Xとはまったく無関係な別の手順で
ランダムに選ぶことを想像してほしい。
例えば、ある人がコインを投げ、
別の部屋にいる別の人が
サイコロを振る場合、
これが異なる組み合わせの確率を
求めるために使う式だ。
状態の組み合わせに対して。定義の要点は、
独立性とはその式が成り立つ場合だということだ。
確率的状態を確率ベクトルで考えると、
この条件の
単純な定式化がある。
具体的には、XYの確率的状態があり、
それをディラック記法のベクトルとして
表現できるとする。
ここに見えるように。XとYが独立であるとは、
2つの確率ベクトルが
存在することと同値だ。
|Φ⟩と|Ψ⟩、簡潔にΦとΨと読んでいいが、
これらはそれぞれXとYの
確率的状態を表していて、
ここに見えるこの等式を
満たすものだ。
すべてのaとbの選択に対して。これは本質的に
定義をベクトルで言い換えたものだ。
例えば、これはXとYが独立な
ビット対XYの確率的状態だ。
独立性に必要な
条件は、ここに見えるベクトルに対して
成り立っている。
つまり、2つのビットの各可能な設定の確率は、
個々のビットの対応する確率の
積で与えられる。
例えば、両方のビットが0の値を取る確率は
6分の1であり、これは4分の1かける
3分の2に等しい。
他の3つの可能性についても同様で、
一つずつ確認できる。
一方、先ほど見た確率的状態では、
常に同じ値を取り、確率2分の1で
0または1の値を取る2つのビットがある。
これは独立ではなく、だからこそ
ビットが相関していると言う。
相関とは単に
独立性の欠如を意味する。
2つのビットが独立でないことを示す
簡単な方法は、独立だと仮定して
矛盾を導くことだ。
具体的には、2つのビットが独立であれば、
q0、q1、r0、r1という
数が存在しなければならない。
2つの個別ビットの確率を表していて、
ここに示したこれらの方程式が
成り立つようにするためだ。
これらはベクトルから得られる確率で、
これらは独立性の条件によって
必ず真でなければならない方程式だ。
だがここの2番目の等式に注目すると、
q0にr1を掛けたものがゼロに
等しいことが要求されているのがわかる。
しかし2つの実数の積がゼロに等しくなる
唯一の方法は、その数のうち少なくとも
1つがゼロに等しい場合だけだ。
これは実数のゼロ積の性質と
呼ばれることがある。
別の言い方をすると、2つの非ゼロ実数の
積は常に非ゼロだということだ。
だからここのこの等式は、
q0がゼロに等しいかr1がゼロに
等しいかのどちらかを意味している。
しかし最初と最後の等式から、
その2つの選択肢のどちらも
真でありえないことがわかる。
q0がゼロに等しければ、この積はゼロに
等しくなければならないが、ゼロに等しくない。
そしてr1がゼロに等しければ、
この積はゼロに等しくなければならないが、
それも真ではない。
つまり矛盾が生じるので、XとYは
独立でないと結論づけられる。
だから相関している。
先ほど議論した独立性の概念、
特に確率ベクトルによる定式化は、
密接に関係している。
テンソル積として知られる、
ベクトルに対して行える
演算と関係しているんだ。
テンソル積はベクトルだけでなく
行列に対しても定義できるし、
実はテンソル積の概念は次のように定義できる。
他の多くの種類の
数学的オブジェクトに対しても同様だ。
かなり抽象的な方法で記述でき、
純粋数学において重要かつ有用だが、
ベクトルに対してテンソル積を
定義することもできる。
非常にシンプルで具体的な方法でも
できるし、この授業ではその道を
たどることにする。
PhiとPsiという2つの列ベクトルが、
sigmaとgammaを任意の古典状態集合の
選択としてここに示した形で書かれているとしよう。
あるいはインデックスでもいいが、
これらのベクトルのテンソル積は
ここに示したベクトルだ。
sigmaとgammaの2つの集合の
デカルト積のすべての要素を見ていき、
これに対応するこのベクトルのエントリは次のようになる。
各ペアabに対して、ここに文字列として
書かれているが、対応するエントリの
積に等しい。
これら2つのベクトルのエントリのことだ。
言い換えれば、Phi テンソル PsiのabエントリはPhiのaエントリと
PsiのbエントリのかけPsiのbエントリの積だ。
そしてそれが
ここに書かれていることの意味だ。
本質的に、これは独立性について
議論したときに少し前に見たのと
同じ演算だ。
そして今はそれに名前を
付けているだけだ。
これはテンソル積の観点から
より明示的に書かれた、
先ほど見たのとまったく同じ例だ。
改めて、6分の1は4分の1かける3分の1に
等しく、12分の1は4分の1かける3分の1に
等しく、といった具合に続く。
ここで、ついでに言うと、
2つのベクトルのテンソル積を書く
代替的な方法がいくつかある。
直接記法を使って、このように2つのketを
隣に並べて書くと、それはテンソル積を意味する。
だからテンソル積は、2つの列ベクトルを
かけ合わせるデフォルトの方法の
ようなものだと考えられる。
行列乗算の観点からこのような
列ベクトルの積を考えても意味がない。
次元が合わないからだ。
だからここでは曖昧さについて
本当に心配する必要はない。
このようにketの中に
テンソル積を書くこともできて、
まったく同じことを意味する。
2つのベクトルの
テンソル積だ。
最初のものは非常に一般的で、
実際テンソル積記号なしでこのように
テンソル積を書く方が一般的かもしれない。
記号を含めるよりもね。2番目のものは
間違いなくはるかに一般的ではないが、
主に次のような場合に非常に役立つことがある。
特定の状況で追加の括弧の
必要性をなくす方法として使われる。
ここに示すように、実際の数値の列の
観点からテンソル積を
明示的に表現することもできる。
ここにある2つの列ベクトルのテンソル積を
取ると、これが得られるベクトルだ。
ここのエントリは、これら2つのベクトルから
来るエントリの積であることが
わかるだろう。
テンソル積のエントリの順序は、
少し前の定義と一致している。
それはデカルト積集合の要素を順序付ける
規則に従っているからだ。
その規則は先ほど説明した
デカルト積集合の要素の
順序付けに関するものだ。
その規則に従うことは、最初のベクトルの
インデックスが2番目のベクトルの
インデックスよりも高い有意性を持つと
考えることと同等だ。
だからテンソル積のエントリを
見ていくと、左側の最初のベクトルの
最初のエントリを含むすべての積がある。
それはalpha oneだ。次に左側のベクトルの
2番目のエントリを含むすべての積が続く。
それはalpha twoで、以下同様だ。
これは左側のベクトルに3つのエントリが
あり、右側のベクトルに4つのエントリがある
例で、何が起きているかより明確に
わかるだろう。
最初のベクトルには3つの要素があるから、まず第2ベクトルのコピーを3つ書き下して、それぞれのコピーに対応する要素を掛けていく
最初のベクトルのこの要素をね、こんな感じで。
alphaをこうして中に入れて、ここではベクトルにスカラーを掛けているだけだ
最後にコピーから括弧を外して、ここで見ての通り1つの列ベクトルにまとめる。
重要な補足として、標準基底ベクトルのテンソル積に関して次の公式が成り立つことに注意してほしい。
cat aとcat bのテンソル積を取ると、テンソル積の記号を使って書いても使わずに書いても、ここで見ての通りどちらでもいいんだが、
結果は単純にcat abになる。
abを文字列ではなく順序対として書きたければそれもできて、ここに示すこの式が得られる。
ただ、もっとよく使われるのはここに書いたこれで、括弧は省いてカンマだけ残す。
ある意味では括弧ありのこっちの方がより正確とも言えるんだが、数学ではかなり標準的な慣習で
必要でも役立つわけでもない括弧は省略する。
こっちの式では括弧が暗黙的に含まれていると考えてもいい、その方がすっきりして見やすいからね。
テンソル積には重要な性質があって、それが双線形性だ。どういうことかというと、線形であるということで
もう一方を固定した場合に、2つの引数それぞれについて成り立つ。
もう少し詳しく言うと、第1引数について線形で、それがここで見ての通りこの2つの等式で表されている。
最初の等式は、Phi1とPhi2という2つのベクトルを足してからPsiとテンソル積を取っても、先にPsiとテンソル積を取ってから
足しても同じ結果になるということを言っている。
2番目の等式は、あるベクトルPhiにスカラーalphaを掛けてからPsiとテンソル積を取っても、
先にPhiとPsiのテンソル積を取ってから結果にalphaを掛けても同じになるということだ。
そして第2引数についても線形性が成り立つ、これは2つの引数の役割が入れ替わるだけで同じだ。
この双線形性という性質は定義から確認するのは割と簡単なんだが、こうして書き下しておくのは良いことで、これらの公式はよく使うからね。
ちなみに、スカラーはテンソル積をくぐり抜けるということに注意してほしい、ここで見ての通りこれらの等式が表している意味でね。
つまり、第1引数にスカラーalphaを掛けても、この場合は第2引数にそのスカラーを掛けても
全体にそのスカラーを掛けても、違いはないということだ。
これらの等式はここに示すこの2つの等式から導かれる、そしてこれらのベクトルの間に違いはないから、ここで見ての通りこの式をそのまま書けばいい
括弧なしで、必要がないからね。
明確さを加えるわけでも曖昧さを取り除くわけでもないから、括弧を外してすっきりした式にする。
これらはすべて3つ以上の系に一般化できる。
3つ以上のベクトルのテンソル積は、2つのベクトルのテンソル積の公式を自然な形で一般化することで定義できる。
ここに示す通りだ。テンソル積の各要素は、テンソル積を取っているベクトルの対応する要素の積で与えられる
ベクトルたちのね。
3つ以上のベクトルのテンソル積を定義するもう一つの方法は、再帰的に行うことで、最終的には
2つのベクトル間のテンソル積の定義に帰着させる。つまりnが3以上なら、nベクトルのテンソル積について
Phi1からPhi nまでを、最初のn minus 1個のテンソル積を取って得られるベクトルと最後のベクトルとのテンソル積だと考えられる。
最初のn minus 1個のベクトルのテンソル積が何かを知りたければ、n minus 1が
3以上の場合は再び同じ公式を適用するか、n minus 1が2に等しい場合は前の定義を使えばいい。
3つ以上のベクトルのテンソル積についてこの2つの考え方は等価だ。
3つ以上のベクトルのテンソル積を取る場合、双線形という用語は使わない。
代わりに多線形という用語を使うが、考え方は同じだ。
テンソル積は各位置について線形で、他のすべての位置のベクトルが
固定されていることが条件だ。次は確率的状態にある複数の系の測定に移ろう。
複数の系をまとめて1つの系として考えるだけで、複数の系に対して測定がどう機能するかの仕様がすぐに得られる
すべての系が測定されることが前提で。
簡単な例として、2つのビットXとYがあって、まとめるとここに示すこの確率的状態にあるとしよう。
これは前に見たやつだ。当然、これら2つのビットを両方測定すると、結果00が得られる
つまり最初の測定でゼロ、2番目の測定でゼロ、確率は1/2で、結果1,1も得られる
確率は2分の1だ。これはごく明快だ。
要するに、すべての系を測定することは、
化合系全体を測定することと同等だ。
しかし、すべての系を測定するのではなく、
一部の系だけを測定する場合には、
状況はすぐには
明確にはならない。できるだけ単純な設定で
本質を理解するために、
2つの系の場合に絞って考えよう。
次の問いを立てることができる。X と Y という
2つの系がペアとして存在するとしよう。
ある特定の確率的状態にある場合だ。
X だけを測定して、Y には何もしない場合、
何が起きるだろうか？
この問いは、基本的な確率論を使って
答えられる。
まず、測定が特定の結果を与える確率は、
ここに示す式で与えられなければならないとわかる。
ペア XY の各古典状態の確率について、
両方を測定した場合として考え、
確率をすべて足し合わせる。
ここで足し合わせるのは、X が
注目する任意の古典状態 a にある場合と
整合する確率だ。
だから、ここの和は Y の古典状態 b だけについて
取るわけだ。
この式の一つの解釈は、X を測定したときに
特定の古典状態を観測する確率は、
実際には Y を測定しなかったとしても、
Y も測定した場合にその状態を観測する確率と
整合しなければならないということだ。
これは非常に自然で直感的だ。X の測定が
特定の結果をもたらす確率は、Y が
結果に関わらず、
測定されたかどうかに依存する可能性はない。
これで測定の異なる結果に対する確率はわかるが、
その結果として Y の状態、あるいは
Y に関する知識はどうなるのか？
答えは、X を測定した結果として、
Y の状態についてまだ不確実性が
存在し得るということだ。
特定の結果を観測した場合、その不確実性は、
条件付き確率のこの式で表される。
X がある古典状態にあるという条件のもとで、
Y が特定の古典状態 b にある確率だ。
測定した古典状態 a が
何であれ、だ。
正確には、X が古典状態 a にあるという条件のもとで、
Y が古典状態 b にある確率は、
X が a にあり Y が b にある確率を、
X が
古典状態 a にある確率で割ったものに等しい。
つまり X を測定すると、
ここに示す式で決まる確率で
様々な古典状態が観測される。
どの結果が得られるかによって、
Y の古典状態についてまだ不確実性が残ることがあり、
その不確実性は
ここに示す式で表される。
実はこれをすべて言い換えて、
直接記法を使って特定のケースの計算を行う
非常に簡単な方法がある。それはこうだ。
まず XY の確率的状態をこのようなベクトルとして
書き下す。これは完全に一般的だ。
成分は Pab で表され、ベクトル全体が
確率ベクトルである限り、
これらは任意の数でよい。
cat ab をここに示すようなテンソル積として表し、
テンソル積の双線形性を使うことができる。
具体的には第2引数の線形性を利用して、
このベクトルをここに示すように表す。
やっていることは実質的に、
左辺の標準基底ベクトルを分離し、
右辺に必要なものを置くことだ。
それが最初の系 X を測定したときに何が起きるかを
明らかにするためだ。
具体的には、特定の結果 a を得る確率は、
cat a の隣の括弧内に現れる
確率の総和だ。
特定の結果 a を得た条件のもとで、
Y に残る不確実性を表す確率ベクトルは
a の隣の括弧内にあったベクトルだ。
ただし、それを確率ベクトルにするために
正規化する必要があり、
つまりそのベクトルを
そのベクトルの成分の総和で割って
確率ベクトルを作る必要がある。
ちなみにここでは、混乱を避けるために
別の変数名を使い、b ではなく
gamma の c について総和を取っている。
変数のスコープについて
混乱しないようにするためだ。
分子と分母の和は別々のものとして
考える必要があり、それについて
混乱する余地を排除するために
2つの和に異なる変数を
使うのだ。
これがどう機能するかを示す
簡単な例を見てみよう。
XY がこの確率的状態にある1ビットのペアだとしよう。
最初のビットを測定したときに何が起きるかを理解するために、
2番目には何もしない場合、ベクトルをここに示すように書く。
cat zero と cat one が最初の位置に
先ほど説明したように
分離されている。
最初の可能性は、測定結果がゼロで、
それが起きる確率は括弧内の確率の
総和だ。
cat zeroにテンソル積をとったものだ。つまり12分の1と4分の1を足して3分の1になり、
結果がゼロという条件のもとで、
Yの確率的な状態は
このベクトルを正規化したもの、つまり確率で
割ったものになる。さっき計算したやつだ。だから得られるのは
このベクトルってわけだ。
もう一つの可能性は測定結果が1の場合で、計算は
式の第2項を使って
同じように行う。第1項じゃなくてな。詳細を確認したければ、いつものようにビデオを一時停止して自分でやってみるといい。
Xじゃなく
Yを測定した場合に何が起きるか調べるためにも、
同じ種類の計算ができる。
方法は同じで、2つのシステム間の対称性によって変わるだけだ。
今度は確率ベクトルをこのように書く。右側の標準基底ベクトルを
ここで見えるように分離してな。
それ以外はまったく同じように
機能する。
このメソッドは
2つ以上のシステムにも使える。
必要な式を全部書き下すのが
少し煩雑になるかもしれないが、概念的には
まったく同じ考え方だ。
最後に、レッスンの古典情報の部分として、
複数のシステムの確率的状態に対する操作を
見ていく。
これまで何度か見てきたのと同じ推論に従えば、
複数のシステムに対する確率的操作は、単一システムに対する確率的操作と
まったく同じで、
確率行列で表現されると結論づけられる。
ただし今度は、その行列の行と列が
各システムの古典状態の集合の
直積に対応している。
つまり複合システムを単一システムとみなして、
確率的操作がどのように機能するかという記述に
立ち戻るだけだ。
単一システムの場合は
前のレッスンで扱った。
ここに、2ビットXとYに対する
controlled-NOT操作と呼ばれる操作の例がある。
これは実際には決定論的操作で、動作としては
Xが1に等しい場合、YにNOT操作が行われる。
それ以外、Xが0に等しい場合は
何も起こらない。
ビットXは制御ビットと呼ばれることがある。
YにNOT操作を適用するかどうかを
決定するからだ。
そしてYはターゲットビットと呼ばれる。NOT操作によって
作用を受けるビットだからだ。
XとYの役割を入れ替えて、Yが制御
ビットになりXがターゲットになることも想像できるが、
それは別の操作だ。
ここで説明している操作とは異なる。XとYの間で
対称ではないからな。
どちらも
controlled-NOT操作と呼ばれる。どのビットが制御ビットで
どれがターゲットビットかを
指定するだけでいい。
この操作は標準基底状態に対して
ここで見えるような作用を持ち、
その定義と照らし合わせて
確認できる。そしてこれが
この操作の行列表現だ。
この操作について考えるとき、2つの別々のビットがあって
さっき説明した役割を担っている、
つまりXが制御ビットで
Yがターゲットビットだというイメージがあるわけだが、
この作用やこの行列表現には実は
この2つのビットを別々のビットとして
考えることを要求するものは
何もない。
代わりに、この操作を4つの古典状態を持つ
システムに対する決定論的な
操作として
考えることもできる。その状態を
0,0、0,1、1,0、1,1と名付けることにしよう。
ここにもう一つの例がある。
2ビットに対する確率的操作で、今度は決定論的な
操作ではない。
この操作は確率2分の1でYをXに等しく設定し、そうでなければ逆方向、つまりXをYに等しく設定する。
この操作に特別な名前はない。単なる例として挙げているだけだ。
そしてこれが
この操作の行列表現だ。
2つの行列の平均として表現できることがわかる。一方は
決定論的操作を表す行列で、
Xに格納されている値にYが設定される場合で、
もう一方はXをYに等しく設定する場合だ。
つまり前のレッスンと同様に、確率行列の平均を取って新しい行列を得られることがわかる。
では次の問いを考えてみよう。2つの
確率的操作があり、それぞれが独自のシステムに対して
通常通り確率行列で記述されている場合、
具体的に言うとMが
システムXに対する確率的操作で、NがシステムYに対する
確率的操作だとしよう。
問いはこうだ。XにMを、YにNを
同時に適用した場合、これが
複合システムXYに与える影響をどう表現するか？
少し直感的に考えてみると、
それぞれのシステムに対して2つの操作を同時に
行っているなら、
実際には複合システムに対して
操作を行っているわけだから、
何らかの確率行列で記述できるはずだ。
この問いへの短い答えは、その行列は
テンソル積を取ることで得られる。
さっき話したようなベクトル間のテンソル積ではなく、
でも今回の場合は行列間、
つまり行列MとNの間のテンソル積だ。
では少し時間を取って
行列のテンソル積について説明して、それからこの問いに戻ろう。
これが行列間のテンソル積の定義で、
ベクトル間のテンソル積と非常によく似ている。
ここで見ているような形で書かれた
2つの行列を扱っているとして、Mの成分はαabと表し、aとbは
古典的状態集合σ上を動き、Nの成分は
βcdと表し、cとdは
古典的状態集合γ上を動くとする。
するとMとNの積はここに見える行列になる。
ベクトルのテンソル積と
似た形になっている。
M tensor Nの行と列は、ここに文字列として書かれた
古典的状態のペアに対応していて、
成分はMとNの対応する成分の積になっている。
個々の行列の成分を使った
別の書き方もある。
M tensor NのacbdエントリはMのabエントリと
NのcdエントリののProduct だ。
M tensor Nを記述する別の方法は、
PhiとPsiのtesor積の形のベクトルを
MをPhiに作用させたものとNをPsiに作用させたものの
テンソル積に変換する唯一の行列であるということで、これはすべての選択に対して成り立たなければならない。
つまりベクトルPhiとPsiのすべての選択に対してだ。
一つの考え方は、行列のテンソル積が
ベクトル間のテンソル積と完全に整合しているということだ。
これは当然成り立ってほしい等式で、
実際そうなっている。
明示的に書き出した行列に関しては、
ここに見えるようにテンソル積を定義できる。
この式にはドットがたくさんあって、パターンを示すためのもので、
ベクトルで持っていたのと同じパターンだが、今は行と列がある。
列ベクトルだけではなく、行と列の両方だ。
わかりにくい場合は、
次の例が助けになるかもしれない。
ここでは2×2行列のテンソル積について
話している。
まず2番目の行列の4つのコピーを書き下す。
1番目の行列の各成分に対して1つずつだ。
2番目の行列のこれらのコピーそれぞれを
1番目の行列の対応する成分で掛ける。
そしてすべてをここに見える
1つの4×4行列にまとめる。
3つ以上の行列のテンソル積も
同様の方法で定義でき、おそらく最も簡単な表現方法は
ここに見えるもので、テンソル積の各成分の式があり、
それは単純に対応する成分の積だ。
3つ以上の行列のテンソル積を、
ベクトルで行ったのと同様に、2つの行列のテンソル積で再帰的に定義することもできる。
最後に注意しておくと、行列のテンソル積は乗法的で、
つまりテンソル積の積は
積のテンソル積に等しい。
これは少し前に述べた、テンソル積行列の
ベクトルへの作用に関する式の一般化だと考えられる。
テンソル積ベクトルへの作用についてだ。これも確かに成り立ってほしいことで、
実際そうなっているのは喜ばしいことだ。
必要なときにはこの
事実を活用していく。
さて、前の問いに戻ろう。システムXに操作Mを行い、
システムXに操作Mを行うとき、その効果をどう記述するかという問いだ。
システムYに操作Nを行い、それを複合システムXY上の
操作として合わせてどう記述するかだ。
その問いへの答えは、
作用はMとNのテンソル積で記述されるということだ。
テンソル積は今回は操作間の独立性を表していて、
確率ベクトルで見たものとは対照的だ。
簡単な例を見てみよう。ビットXに対して
この行列で記述される確率的操作を行うとしよう。
これはレッスン1で見た操作で、
同時にビットYにNOT操作を行う。
ペアXYへの合成操作はしたがって、
これら2つの操作に対応する行列のテンソル積で表される。
こちらがX上の操作で、
こちらがY上のNOT操作で、ここに見えるこの行列が得られる。
確かにこれは確率的行列で、
常にそうなる。
任意の2つの確率的行列のテンソル積、
いや任意の数の確率的行列のテンソル積も常に確率的になる。
ある操作が1つのシステムに行われ、
別のシステムには何もしないという状況は非常によくある。
この状況では、何もしないことは単位行列で表されるという理解のもと、
まったく同じ方法に従う。
例えば、2つのビットXとYがあり、
ビットXをゼロ状態にリセットするとして、これは
Xに対して定数ゼロ関数を実行するのと同じで、
Yには何もしない場合、ペアXYへの結果の操作は
このtensor productで
表されてる。
これは全部、任意の数のシステムに
一般化できて、量子の設定に移ったときに
追加の例をいくつか見ることになる。
まったく同じように動く。
確率的行列じゃなくてユニタリ行列を
使うっていう違いがあるだけで、
古典情報についてはここまでにする。
次は量子情報に注目して、
複数のシステムでどう動くか見ていく。
パターンは古典情報のときと
同じだ。
複数の量子システムを単一の複合システムとして
扱えて、前回のレッスンで知ったことを
そのまま適用できる。
ここでもtensor productが
重要な役割を果たして、
全体として複数のシステムに対する
量子情報の動き方の説明が得られる。
これは今見てきた古典情報と
非常によく似ていて、
数学的にも類似してる。
量子状態から始めよう。
複数のシステムの量子状態は、
複素数を成分とする列ベクトルで表されて、
Euclidノルムが1に等しい。
単一システムの量子状態と
まったく同じだ。
今回は、量子状態ベクトルのインデックスが
各システムの古典状態集合の
直積集合に対応してる。
なぜならそれが複合システムの
古典状態集合だから。
例えば、XとYがqubitなら、
XYの組み合わせの古典状態集合は
二値アルファベットとそれ自身の
直積集合になる。
これは長さ2の二進文字列の集合として
考えることができる。
だから、ここに見えるこれらのベクトルは
すべてXYの量子状態ベクトルの例だ。
別の書き方をしたければ、
各qubitに対して別々のketを使って
こう書くこともできる。
ket間のtensor productは
暗黙のものとしてね。
好みによっては、こんな感じで
tensor productの記号を
明示的に書いてもいい。
もう一つの選択肢は、
ket表すシステムの名前を
添字として付けること。
これはtensor productの記号あり
でもなしでもできる。
これが混乱を避けるのに
とても役立つことがある。
これらは同じベクトルを表す
単なる違うスタイルで、
好きなもの、気に入ったもの、
あるいは一番意味をなすものを
選べる。
状況によっては、ものごとが
もっと複雑になってきたとき、
あるスタイルの方が
明確さを加えると判断するかもしれない。
どれを選ぶかは
自由だ。
量子状態ベクトルのtensor productも
また量子状態ベクトルだ。
例えば2つのシステムの場合、
PhiがシステムXの量子状態ベクトルで、
PsiがシステムYの量子状態ベクトルなら、
PhiとPsiのtensor productは
XYの量子状態ベクトルになる。
こういう状態をproduct stateと呼ぶ。
確率論的な設定で見たのと同様に、
これらはシステムXとYの間の
独立性を表してる。
例えば、世界のある場所に
実験室を持つ人がシステムXを作って、
量子状態Phiに初期化したとして、
世界の別の場所にいる別の人が
独立にシステムYを量子状態Psiに
初期化したとする。
そのとき、たとえXYが世界の
異なる場所にある2つの部分であっても、
XYを単一のシステムとして
考えることにしたなら、
複合システムXYは
Phi tensor Psiという状態にある。
これは全部、2つ以上のシステムに対して
自然な形で一般化される。
独立したシステムXn〜Xnの
量子状態Psi1〜PsiNがあるとき、
このn個のベクトルのtensor productは
量子状態を表す。これは複合システム
X1〜XnのProduct stateと呼ばれる。
ここに2つのqubitの
量子状態の例がある。
すぐにはそう見えないかもしれないけど、
これはproduct stateの例だ。
なぜなら、ここに見えるように
tensor productとして書けるから。
つまり、どう書かれているかに関わらず
product stateの例なんだ。
関係あるのは、tensor productとして
書けるかどうかだ。
しかしこの量子状態、これもまた
2つのqubitの状態だが、
product stateじゃない。
確率論的な設定で見た、
完全に相関した2つのランダムビットの
例と精神的に似てる。
同じ議論によって、これが
tensor productとして書けないことが
わかる。
じゃあこれをここに移して、
もう少し詳しく議論を見てみよう。
この状態が2つのベクトル
PhiとPsiのtensor productとして
書けると仮定してみよう。
古典状態0,1に対応するエントリは
このベクトルでゼロだが、
見ればすぐわかる。
しかしこれが2つのベクトルの
tensor productだとしたら、
Phiのゼロエントリと
Psiの1エントリの積が
ゼロに等しいことを意味するが、
それはつまり、Phiのゼロエントリか
Psiの1エントリのどちらかがゼロ、
あるいは両方ともゼロかもしれないけど、
それはここにあるこの2つの積が
どちらも非ゼロでなければならないという
事実と矛盾する。
それらは2の平方根分の1に等しい。この議論は実は、確率的な設定で使ったものとほぼ同じだ。
これはまったく量子固有のものじゃない。
いずれにせよ、元の状態は積状態じゃないとわかる。
ここにある2つの数が2の平方根分の1であることは重要じゃないことに注目してほしい。
重要なのは、両方の値がゼロでないということだけだ。
この特定の量子状態はとても興味深いものだ。2つのqubitの絡み合い状態の例だ。
絡み合いについては、このシリーズの後半でさらに話す。
絡み合いは複雑になりうる。特に量子情報の一般的な定式化における量子状態について話すときはそうだ。
でもここでは量子情報の簡略化された記述において、絡み合いは独立性の欠如と等価だ。
だから量子状態ベクトルにとって、積状態でなければ絡み合い状態であり、この特定の状態は
絡み合い量子状態の典型的な例として一般的に見なされている。
実際、この状態を1単位の絡み合いを表すものとして考えることがある。特に絡み合いを
面白いことをするために使えるリソースとして考えるときはそうだ。
今話した量子状態は、いわゆるbell状態の4つのうちの1つだ。ここでそれらと名前が見られる。
これらの状態によく使われる名前は、Phi plus、Phi minus、Psi plus、Psi minusだ。
すべて絡み合っており、2つのqubitの状態を表すすべてのベクトルの空間の基底を形成している。
つまりこの4つのベクトルをまとめてBell基底と呼ぶ。
これはとてもよく登場する量子状態の集合で、1960年代に絡み合いの研究に非常に重要な貢献をした物理学者、John Bellにちなんで名付けられている。
John Bellは1960年代に絡み合いの研究に貢献した。
3つのqubitの量子状態のよく知られた例をいくつか挙げよう。
最初のものはGHZ状態と呼ばれる。
これはさっき見たPhi plus状態に似ているが、2つのqubitじゃなく3つのqubitのためのものだ。
2つ目の例はW状態と呼ばれ、ここで見るとおりの形をしている。ちょうど1ビットが1に設定されている3つの2進文字列に対して
一様に分布している。長さ3で、1が1つだけ立っているものだ。
これらの状態のどちらも積状態ではなく、どちらも興味深い性質を持ち、例としてかなりよく登場する。だから知っておくといい。またこれらを見ることになる。
次は量子状態にあるシステムの測定について話す。
このレッスンでここまで従ってきた同じ論法に従って、複数のシステムを
単一のシステムとして考えるという方法で、複数の量子システムの測定がどう機能するかの記述に即座に到達する。
すべてのシステムが測定される場合に限ってだ。
つまり、n個のシステムのn-tupleの量子状態を表す量子状態ベクトルPsiがあるとすると
X1からXnまで、複合システム全体を測定したとき、それはすべての個々のシステムを測定することと等価だが、
各古典状態のn-tupleが測定の結果となる確率は
そのn-tupleに対応するPsiの成分の絶対値の2乗に等しい。
例えば、ここにある量子状態でXYという2つのシステムのペアがあれば、両方のシステムを測定したとき、
結果はzero heartsとなる。つまりXの測定でzero、Yの測定でheartsだ。
確率は9/25で、結果one speedsとなる確率は16/25だ。
これは実にわかりやすい。基本的に2つの別々のシステムであるという事実を無視して、1つの単一システムとして見ている。
でもこれは次の自然な疑問を引き起こす。古典的な設定でもすでに考えた疑問だ。
XとYという2つのシステムがあり、まとめて何らかの量子状態にあるとしよう。両方は測定せず、
一方だけを測定するとしよう。Xを測定してYには何もしないとしよう。
もちろん、YだけでなくXを測定したらどうなるか、さらに一般的に3つ以上のシステムがある場合に
その適切な部分集合だけを測定したらどうなるかも聞ける。でもこの問いに答えれば、それらの問いにも答えられる。
一般に、XYペアの量子状態ベクトルはここで見るとおりの形を取ることがわかっている。いつものようにsigmaとgammaは
それぞれXとYの古典状態集合だと仮定する。
このベクトルの成分はalpha abと表され、aとbのすべての可能な選択にわたる。
それらはこのベクトルを単位ベクトルにする任意の複素数でよい。
両方のシステムが測定された場合、異なる可能な結果の確率が得られることはすでにわかっている。
対応するエントリの絶対値の2乗を取ることで求められる。
Xだけが測定される場合、特定の結果aを
得る確率はこの式で表される。
Yも測定された場合に得られうる
すべての可能な結果bについて
単純に総和を取ればいい——たとえYが測定されなかったとしても。
この考え方は確率論的な設定と
同じだ。
Xが測定されたときに特定の結果を得る確率は、
Yも測定されたかどうかには
依存しないはずだ。
つまりこれが、さまざまな可能な結果に対する
確率を教えてくれる。
さらに、Xにこの測定を行って
特定の結果を得た結果として、
Yの状態にも何らかの変化が生じる。
では、これがどう機能するか見てみよう。
確率論的な設定でやったことと同様に、
量子状態ベクトルPsiをここに示すように
表現できる。
ここでPhi aは、システムXの古典的な状態aの
各選択に対するベクトルだ。
以前と同じようにテンソル積の
双線形性を使っている。
ただし今回は利便性のために、
これらの異なるベクトルをPhi aと
名付けることにした。
測定が各可能な結果aをもたらす確率は
ここに示すとおりであることはすでに確認したが、
今度はこの確率がベクトルPhi aの
ユークリッドノルムの2乗に等しいことが
わかる。
そして、Xの測定が特定の結果aを与えた結果として、
複合システムXYの量子状態は
ここに示すこの状態に
なる。
単一システムの場合と同様に、状態は本質的に収縮するが、
一般的には完全には収縮しない。
Xの測定が結果aをもたらすことと
整合するために必要な分だけ
収縮するにすぎない。
YのqubitになるPhi aは正規化される——つまり
ユークリッドノルムで割る。
単位ベクトルになるようにだ。これは確率論的な設定で
起きたことに類似しており、
ユークリッドノルムで割る代わりに、
確率ベクトルを得るために
Phi aのエントリの総和で
割っていた。
ここでは量子状態について
話しているので、量子状態ベクトルを得るために
ユークリッドノルムで割る。
特定の状態でこれがどう機能するか、
いくつかの例を見てみよう。
これが考察する状態だ。XとYはqubitで、
この特定の状態Psiにあると仮定する。
そしてXが測定されるとしよう。
まず状態PsiをここでXの
標準基底の因子を効果的に分離しながら、
ここに示すように書く。
そして元の状態を得るために必要なものと
テンソル積を取る。
先ほどの一般的な説明と
全く同じだ。
結果ゼロを得る確率は、
ここに示すこのベクトルのユークリッドノルムの
2乗だ。
ベクトルPsiの表現においてket zeroにテンソル積を取っているものだ。
よって確率は4分の3で、
結果ゼロを得ることを条件とすると、
組み合わせXYの量子状態は、
ket zeroにテンソル積を取ったベクトルを
正規化したこの状態になる。
これは、今計算した確率の
平方根で割ることと
同等だ。
簡略化するとこうなる。
測定結果1を得る確率は
同様の方法で計算される。
Psiの表現においてket oneにテンソル積を取っている
ここに示すこのベクトルの
ユークリッドノルムの2乗を取ると、
結果として得られる確率は4分の1だ——当然そうなる、
なぜなら確率の総和は
1でなければならないからだ。
この場合、XYの量子状態はこうなる——再びユークリッドノルムで割って
正規化している。
その結果としてこの量子状態ベクトルが
得られる。
XではなくYが測定される場合も、
対称的な方法で同じ手法が使われる。
元の量子状態ベクトルはこれで、今度はXではなく
Yが測定されるので、
ベクトルPsiをここに示すように表現する——
今度はYの標準基底ベクトルを
分離する。
PsiのXではなく、
Psiの表現を得るために必要なものと
テンソル積を取りながら。
計算を進めると——ビデオを一時停止して
確認したければそうしてもいい。
今度は結果ゼロを得る確率は
8分の5で、ここに
量子状態ベクトルがある。
その結果を得ることを条件として
生じるものだ。
そして結果1を得る確率は8分の3で、
その場合はこれが
量子状態ベクトルになる。
2つ以上のシステムがある場合でも、
それらの適切な部分集合が測定されれば
全く同じ方法が使える。
このレッスンの教科書コンテンツに例が載っているから、
興味があれば確認してみるといい。
要するに、システムを常に二つの別々の集まりに分けられる——測定されるものと、されないものだ。
それが済んだら、今説明した方法に立ち戻る。
これが複数の量子システムにおける測定の仕組みだ。
そして最後に、複数システムに対する
ユニタリ演算に移る。
複数のシステムを一つの複合システムとして見られるという
同じ基本的な考え方を使う。
画面に表示されているものが結論だ——複合システムに対する量子演算は
ユニタリ行列で表される。
単一システムと同じで、特にそのユニタリ行列の行と列は
デカルト積に対応している。
扱っているシステムの集まりがどれであれ、
その古典状態集合のデカルト積だ。
例えば、システムXの古典状態が1、2、3で
YがQubitの場合、
ここに見えるこの行列が、
ペアXYに対する演算を表すユニタリ行列の例だ。
以前話したデカルト積の順序付けの詳細は、
この例においてはあまり関係ない——これはただの6×6行列で、
たまたまユニタリなだけだ。
特別なものではないが、いくつかの重要な行列から
構成されている。
ポイントは、6×6のユニタリ行列であれば
どれでも選べて、それがXYに対するユニタリ演算を表すということだ。
ユニタリ演算の集まりをそれぞれ自分のシステムに対して
独立に適用した場合、それら全体の作用は
複合システムに対してテンソル積で
与えられる。
画面にはその事実のより正確な
記述が見える。
ユニタリ演算がユニタリ行列U1からUnで記述される場合——それぞれのシステムに一つずつ——
複合システムに対する結合された作用は
U1からUnのテンソル積で与えられる。
確率論的な設定と同様に、重要な例として、
あるユニタリ演算をシステムXに適用し、
別のシステムYには
何もしないというケースがある。
XYに対する演算はUと単位行列のテンソル積になる。
単位行列はYに何もしないことを
表している。
この単位行列がシステムYに対応すると明示的に書くと
式がより明確になって便利なことがある。
一つの方法は、それが作用するシステムを示す
添え字を単位行列につけることだ。
十分明確な場合は普通添え字をつけないが、
複雑になってきたときには非常に役立つ。
対称なケースも考えられる——ユニタリ演算Vが
Yに適用されてXには何もしない場合だ。
このときXYに対する結果の
ユニタリ演算は、ここに示すテンソル積で表される。
ここでも、役立つなら
単位行列に添え字をつけられる。
具体的な例をいくつか見てみよう。
XとYがQubitで、XにHadamard演算を行い
Yには何もしない場合、ここに見える行列が得られる。
一方、YにHadamard演算を行いXには何もしない場合、
テンソル積の順序が逆になる。
だからここに見える
行列が得られる。
複合システムに対するすべてのユニタリ演算が
テンソル積として表せるわけではない。
テンソル積があれば
独立性がある。
複数のシステムに対して明らかに独立には
作用しない演算の、かなり基本的な例がある。
例えば、XとYが同じ古典状態集合を持っている場合——
それはどんな古典状態集合シグマでもいい——
ペアXYに対するswap演算について
考えられる。
この演算は二つのシステムの順序を変えない——左にX、右にYのままだ——
しかし、中身を
入れ替えることを表している。ここでは二つの量子状態の
テンソル積の形を使った方程式でそれが表現されている。
別の書き方として、ここで見るような
行列表現がある。
この表現の考え方は、標準基底ベクトルに対して
何が起きるかを教えてくれるということだ。
標準基底ベクトルに対して何が起きるかが分かれば、
線形性によって任意の量子状態に対して何が起きるかも分かる。
実はこの表現についても
同様だ。
だからこの演算は、ユニタリ演算であると同時に
決定論的演算でもある。
XとYがQubitの場合、例えば
ここに示す行列表現が得られる。
swap演算と4つのBell状態の間には
興味深い関係がある——便宜上ここに示している。
swap演算は最初の三つをそのままにするが、
Psiマイナス状態の前にマイナス符号をつける。
だから、あれには
特別なところがある。
これらの方程式は、これらのベクトルを直接見て、
標準基底状態に対して何が起きるかを考えることで確認できる。
最初の三つのBell状態の二つの古典状態を入れ替えても
何も変わらない——始めたのと同じ状態が得られる。
しかし四番目のケースでは、古典状態のswapを行うと
マイナス符号が実質的に一方の項からもう一方へ移動する。
それはベクトルにマイナス1をかけるのと同等だ。
つまりswap演算を行うと、この四番目のBell状態から
マイナス符号が弾き出されるわけだ。
これらの方程式については後でまた話すが、
今は別のタイプの演算、つまり制御演算に移ろう。
XがQubitで、Yはどんなシステムでもいいとしよう。
UがYに対するユニタリ演算なら、XYに対する制御U演算とは
ここに表現されている演算だ。
まず直接表記を使い、次にブロック行列と呼ばれるものを使う——この大きな行列を
小さい行列で埋めていくイメージで、ゼロはゼロで埋まった行列を表している。
つまりこの四つのブロックそれぞれが、
Yの古典状態の数に一致する行と列を持つ行列を表している。
制御演算のアイデアは、古典的な設定で
制御NOT演算について議論したときに既に出てきたが、
Xがゼロにセットされていれば
Yには何も起きない。
しかしXが1にセットされていれば
YにUが適用される。
だからXは制御Qubitと呼ばれ、Yはターゲットシステムと呼ばれる——
一般にQubitである必要はない。
具体的な例として、今ちょうど触れたのが制御NOT演算だ。
特定の例として、
今ちょうど触れた制御NOT演算がある。
最初のqubitがゼロにセットされていれば何も起きない。最初のqubitが1にセットされていれば、NOT演算、つまり同等に
シグマX演算が
二番目のQubitに適用される。
そしてこれが行列表現だ。
ここで話しているのは二つのQubitだから、
二番目のQubitを制御にして最初をターゲットにすることも
同様に決められる。
その演算を記述するには、テンソル積の順序を入れ替えるだけで、
結果はここに見える行列だ。
制御NOT演算の代わりに、制御シグマZ、つまり
制御Z演算を考えると、
ここに示す行列表現が得られる。そしてこれについては、
どちらが制御でどちらがターゲットかは実際には関係ない。
どちらでも同じ結果が得られる。
さらに進んで、制御swap演算も考えられる。
ここでは二つのQubitのswapについて話しているから、
制御Qubitを含めると三つのQubitになる。
行列表現はそれぞれ
こうなる。
これはかなり特別な演算で、Fredkin演算、またはより一般的にはFredkin gateとして知られている。
circuit内のgateとして考えるとき——circuitについては次のレッスンで議論する。
最後の例は、制御・制御NOT演算で、
これも三つのQubitに対する演算だ。
そしてこれが行列表現だ。この演算はToffli演算またはToffoli gateとして
はるかに広く知られている。
後のレッスンでさらに詳しく議論して、
FrekinとToffoli gate演算の両方がなぜ非常に重要な
演算であるかを見ていく。
これで第2レッスンの終わりだ。このレッスンでは、複数システムに対して量子情報がどう機能するかを議論した。
近々第3レッスンにも参加してほしい——量子circuit、
プロトコル、ゲームについてのレッスンだ。
ではまた。